Scott can you take us through a
realistic scenario of a screenwriter
pitching an idea to an executive where
does it begin
usually it takes a good amount of
schmoozing to get the meeting in the
first place so there is a lot of you
know sort of getting your foot in the
door
professionally when the meeting actually
is secured it usually starts at log
lines usually an executive on the other
side of the room is looking for specific
types of programs they'll want it'll be
kind of overly specific in terms of like
they want mysteries about XYZ they want
romances about ABC and they'll sort of
like walk you through a very clear-cut
expectations of what they're looking for
in a project and they're usually looking
for a list of log lines or very very
short synopses like 100 200 words and
that's usually done by email honestly
when you do secure the meeting and in
today's world it's almost usually Zoom
or some kind of a teleconference you
just sort of walk through those ideas a
bit but it's really much more about
sussing out who you are what you bring
to the table how many variations of the
same thing you can sort of deliver upon
in the hopes of maybe not just doing a
one-time deal but actually building more
of a relationship ship and a partnership
so that you can sort of get repeat
business with a client
so you've already been vetted before
you're doing a zoom meeting okay it's
not just a blind pitch where someone
wants to do their sort of HomeTown Story
and they don't really know the person
they've kind of gone through the proper
channels yeah I mean look it's it's to
get that meeting the process to sort of
reach that
you know it's if you find a company
that's willing to to look at content
from new people that's pretty critical
um so that can be you can reach out to
people via LinkedIn you can reach out to
them you know online you can you can do
enough research and find their contact
details or at least some general you
know info at XYZ company kind of uh uh
email someplace and those will actually
get reviewed and read
um I'm not saying there's a real high
turnover in that but it's a uh it's it's
people do evaluate that and if there is
something there that sort of matches a
general sort of feel of what the company
looks for if it sort of matches the
brand and what that company delivers to
the market
um yeah you usually will have somebody
reach out and it's it's not just one
script they're looking for people who
sort of can deliver
um a high output somebody who's coming
to the table not just with like one
screenplay and that's what they have
they want somebody who has three
screenplays or five screenplays not that
they'd read them all but they just sort
of want to know that this is a writer
who's who can deliver who is kind of a
writing machine so to speak and can just
keep getting new versions as I said sort
of the same thing of the same kind of
genre out there
what's the bare minimum experience
someone has to have to pitch in
Hollywood
you need to be able to show that you've
sort of done the work in a sense the
Catch-22 when starting out for anybody
starting out in a career is you have
zero professional experience but the
people on the other side of a table want
to see that you've done something
they'll look you up on IMDb they'll look
you up your general sort of online
presence to get a sense of Who You Are
and if you're trying to break into
writing or something creative it's
actually quite challenging because if
you don't have those credits in place
sort of how do you prove that what's fun
about today which is very different than
20 years ago 30 years ago is that
anybody can kind of create their own
website and can sort of present
themselves very professionally through
any number of social media Outlets so
you can sort of create your own
personalized brand VIA website or
something else and even if you have no
professional credits you can sort of
showcase some of the um styles that you
work within some of the writing samples
that you have and sort of present
yourself that way uh I think having that
sort of presence is a great start and
then I would say you sort of need a I
call it like a critical mass of of
um materials to be able to show and that
would be like if you want to be a
screenwriter my personal advice is you
need at least two scripts if not three
that would be the ideal and you need
about five to ten like ready to go
fleshed out log line ideas and a log
line being you know 75 words to 100
words Concepts that do show that
beginning middle end concept of a movie
and I think that with that you're sort
of coming to the table
um with a good amount of volume and a
professional background that's enough
sort of to secure that meeting and sort
of get that process going so if you're
going to markets if you're going and
just sort of cold emailing people so to
speak
um you know not everyone's going to
immediately turn and respond right away
but you know you might get you know 15
that do and if they do they can quickly
sort of dive in there and see that no
this person sort of has potential let's
see what they can deliver on let's see
what their log lines are like let's see
what a synopsis looks like maybe they'd
be willing to write on spec and writing
on spec in this case would mean hey
we're doing 20 movies a year and the
network will only buy from us if there's
a script and we don't want to put out X
number of dollars to get a script that
may never get green lit so what if we
worked with a writer on spec we can get
the screenplay for you know a lower
amount up front and then if the green
light takes place the rider gets the
remainder of the money and it's a great
opportunity for for new writers
especially to sort of get their foot in
the door really show a track record with
a Distribution Company or production
company multiple there's you know they
don't have to be exclusive and uh really
start you know kick starting their
career
okay and so what if they've they've done
their homework on the production company
they know that they're going to be
pitching a similar genre they have five
let's say scripts ready to go they have
other ideas but the thing that's going
to get them is their IMDb only shows
like short films but they've actually
done rewrites but it's not reflected in
their IMDb because we hear that a lot in
comments well this person hasn't done
anything but they actually have it just
isn't reflected in their IMDb how do
they how do they kind of handle that
work around that
I mean
on my side of the industry I work very
much on the business side and
um
there's like a fraction of the titles
I've actually worked on in a creative
capacity a development capacity
um a distribution capacity uh I don't
have my name on those films
um and that's how most of us are on our
side and distribution and development
you know we don't we don't get credits
all the time and so uh you showcase it
in other ways basically you know it's
it's much more about the deals I've
closed and sort of the contacts that I
have our business is really built on
relationships
um so I think that if you're a newer
writer or somebody who does have
experience it's about cultivating the
relationships uh my my real view it's
it's like such an old saying but it's
like it's it's really this industry is
built on relationships it's about who
you know that's not enough to just
that's enough to sort of sometimes get a
door open but that's not necessarily
going to land the deal or get your first
opportunity going and that's all on your
own shoulders and that's actually it's a
little bit scary in a sense but in truth
like you have the most control over that
because you can come into the room with
the right kinds of scripts with the
right sorts of ideas with the right
personal
um presentation in the sense of being a
professional and wanting to work and
willing to put in the work to get it
done
why do pitch meetings exist in the first
place Executives sort of have this issue
where they need lots of stuff to make
their jobs functional
and it is impossible for all of those
ideas to come from one place you can't
just create all of them in the boardroom
and they need outside influence they
need
people who are much more in a creative
uh mindset to be able to sort of like
Executives look at these things as
problems it's it's you're walking in
saying you know we need X number of
films this year we need 20 films on our
calendar for Q4 and that's all they're
thinking about is much more just like
what are we going to slate when and
where what are we going to program for
this month what are we going to program
for this quarter and they sort of need
um we need a lot of assistance in terms
of like okay what are we going to fill
that with like
I'm really good at you know getting a
deal together I can get the financing
together I can create the opportunity of
this is the movie we're going to make a
lot of the deals I do we're making we're
making movies before the movie exists
before there's a script it's a concept
but I've closed many many deals that are
just you know a big contract with
financial numbers attached to it and all
the titles are to be determined movie
number one number two number three and
it's a package of films that's when we
go out to creative uh Outlets whether
it's production companies development
Executives that we know screenwriters
that we know and it's much more about
like look we need some films here what
do you have or I set up a deal or I'm
sorry I set up a meeting with um a
network or a VOD platform and they want
to know what films we have and so I will
go out to like writers that we work with
a lot and sort of say
I'm meeting with this client you know
what do you have that sort of matches
these types of genres
um and then I'll just take two or three
log lines that they have I'll put them
all together and we'll present them and
see what sticks so to speak and it's
sort of pitching is much more about
taking the creative aspect of filmmaking
or television production or New Media in
general and making it a business case
or taking the business opportunity and
adding that splash of creativity to it
that makes the whole thing stick
together that's sort of the gist of it
but it's really about like just Fielding
information so we can close the deal
well Hollywood always have pitch
meetings absolutely I mean it's it's
every industry has pitch meetings dating
has pitch meetings it's it's
um pitching is really about
taking your opportunity as a person and
sort of just saying like this is what I
can deliver this is what I can make
happen it's um you have to sort of look
if you just sit around and and wait for
the you know
proverbial phone call like it's never
going to come you know it's you do have
to step out there in the world and sort
of create your own opportunities
opportunities never come in clean neat
packages they're usually problems and
companies have problems all the time and
you know it's it's looking at those and
saying
I can find a way in here get my foot in
the door so to speak and solve that
problem and I have the talents to do it
and here's how and why that's all
pitching is it's it's
every industry every scenario in your
life involves a deal of pitching if
you're negotiating anything in your life
if you're negotiating I don't know with
how you want to decorate your house with
your spouse or partner like you're
pitching ideas and you're presenting
Concepts and bringing that to the table
but in terms of Hollywood in terms of
the media business
that's the only way that you're going to
be able to get your ideas heard is by
sort of expressing what you think a
project could be how you think it should
be executed and I think what you should
also be adding to that is that you're
the most important person to deliver it
because of you know whatever reasons you
want to put in there but that's pitching
it's all just what can you deliver what
can you bring to the table how can you
solve other companies or other people's
problems and that's how you get results
well yeah you always hear about that
when let's say if you've ever watched
any entrepreneurial pitches a TV show or
live it's always because someone wanted
to solve a problem they had and if they
created something for the market but how
does someone know what quote-unquote
problems are at a at a production
company or a network that they could be
the one to solve that in truth there's
always a bit of blindness to it
um even on my end where we're meeting
with you know the heads and the
presidents of networks all the time and
even we are a little bit in the dark to
a degree in terms of like what decisions
have they decided Behind Closed
boardroom doors since the last time we
chatted with them
um but
a great way to look at this is uh if you
most of these companies are like massive
publicly traded companies I'm not an MBA
I'm not like some big business Guru I
just kind of like getting movies made
and I'm sort of more creative on the
deal making side not on the story side
um that's sort of how I look at it but
most of these companies whether it's
Netflix AMC networks Discovery Paramount
they're all publicly traded and why
that's important is that anybody
can get on their website and there's
always going to be some tab in there
called investors and if you get on those
and you can look for documents called
10ks or 10 cues and these are required
by law that they publish these big
documents they're insanely long they're
like 300 400 Pages you don't have to
read them all but if you actually skim
through the first couple of pages
there's usually like a letter from the
CEO there's like a breakdown of the
marketplace there's a breakdown of what
they're trying to do in the next year
the next quarter and they list it all
out there like they literally tell you
like a to B this is what we're trying to
do this is what we're trying to get to
these are the problems we have
and this is how we're trying to adapt in
this Marketplace or be competitive so
they list it all out and what's also
good about those is they actually use
their own every company has like their
own internal language that they use how
they like to talk about problems how
they like to speak about projects it's
all listed in there so that's a really
good resource if you're trying to sort
sort of learn what our company's going
for but truth be told if you're newer to
the industry and you're sort of just
starting out
opening those major doors isn't the most
likely uh direct First Step it's usually
going to be smaller companies that feed
into those big ones so it's going to be
smaller distribution companies
smaller production companies and they're
the ones who are actually producing the
core content that will then be delivered
to those bigger players
so if you are looking at more of The
Originals that are popping up on a lot
of these platforms or networks and you
go look at the companies that are
consistently delivering to them those
are the ones to look at but whatever the
big entity problems are it's also going
to Ripple down to the smaller players
too they're sort of like
I call them Like Satellites like they're
sort of satellite companies and they're
always feeding into those big beasts and
so whatever the big beast is having an
issue with the smaller companies will be
too but
that's a great way to find some
interesting opportunities wow that's
fascinating I might just do that just to
just try your example just because so go
to a publicly traded company and look
for investor info and then kind of it'll
be like a PDF or something and see yeah
like the major companies you can
download it like in any conceivable
format and it's um you can you can
usually search through the document so
if you're looking for something very
specific like
certain titles of movies or TV shows or
certain types of platforms that they
might work with like if you looked into
Fox you know 2B is related to Fox Pluto
is related to Paramount so you can get
in there and actually do a bit of
research on the specific platform you're
looking at so yeah
most screenwriters understand that they
should know the ending of their story
before they start writing can you
explain how the same logic applies to
understanding the business yeah
um that's something I
uh had a challenge sort of defining for
a while myself and then I realized it's
actually a lot simpler than I thought
about it it's just it's it's us it's
it's we call ourselves end users we are
people who actually pay for content
so if you have a Netflix subscription
you're an end user if you pay for
tickets to a movie you're an end user we
are the actual audience that's paying
money and funding the whole
entertainment business
so looking at us what do audiences like
how are we split into groups what genres
pop with certain demographics
that is what Studios care about that's
what networks care about that is what
any sort of consumer direct to Consumer
facing company will care about uh so
it's sort of the same idea they are
using that information to sort of
delineate what content should we go for
what content should we avoid
so if you look at different television
channels they are all targeted to very
sort of specific audience
categories they have similar genres they
have very similar themes
and
they tend to not they tend to speak to
very different groups and they don't
have a whole lot of overlap
I think this is probably the most
visible with cable news where you see
very polarized views of the world
um uh speaking to very specific
audiences and all they care about is
speaking to that one Target and nobody
else if a company is releasing the
Twilight films they're doing the same
thing they really want to Keep Their
audience happy so that they can make the
second and the third film if they're
doing the Fast and Furious franchise
they really want to keep that audience
happy so they can keep sort of churning
out one title to the next so
very long-winded way of answering this
but it's basically you're correct if
you're going to write a script you have
to know how it ends because you
structure everything leading up to it
when we're doing distribution deals when
I'm sort of getting films financed or
getting television shows off the ground
we are thinking the exact same way but
are sort of how are we going to make
this work we're looking at an audience
we're looking at a company that speaks
to that audience because most of what I
do Works in what we call like the B2B or
business to business end of things
I'm doing deals directly with the
studios or I'm doing deals directly with
um other entities that are direct to
Consumer so television channels or VOD
platforms Etc they care about their
audience they want content that's going
to Keep Their audience happy and engaged
and watching I need to give them content
that's going to ensure that that takes
place so I'm absolutely using the
metrics the data the information I can
gather or that they can share with me
about who Their audience is what they
like how they like content to feel how
they like it to be structured how they
like it to flow and then I work
backwards and those are the kinds of
films we look for those are the kinds of
screenplays we try to find we try to
find writers who can sort of deliver in
that world and that's sort of what keeps
that supply chain going
what else do writers need to know about
the traditional script to screen mode of
thinking
I would reverse it it's
I I think when you're starting out it's
it's the whatever is going to get a
couple scripts like under your belt so
to speak like follow it but um once you
sort of get a much better command of
your craft you have the confidence that
you can write feature-length scripts
with relative ease it's not easy at all
but I mean the fact that you know you
can do it once you've sort of reached
that point you need to sort of stop
thinking about
the script to screen approach and start
thinking about what do screens need and
then write that because that's how our
industry really operates it's it's if
you look at the canned film festival or
the Berlin Film Festival
a lot of people have a mindset that the
film gets made and then you take it to
the festival and then sort of present it
to the world with the hope of getting
distribution and it's like no the
distribution was set up before the film
was even shot that's a big marketing
stunt that's just getting it out there
and showing people like look how great
this movie is we want Awards Etc maybe
very small Independent films go to the
markets and haven't yet secured
distribution but the big ones they're
already taken and they're locked and you
sort of have to think about
screenwriting the same way you need to
approach it as what do these television
channels need what do these outlets need
what are the core genres that make that
work uh I've I
wrote about that years and years ago in
in my first book and it was those have
not changed like
Christmas movies they make hundreds
every single year it's like Christmas is
coming this year and I guarantee you
it's going to come next year too and
there's going to be a big content need
and a lot of networks and a lot of TV
channels all over the world
um really Bank on that
action films with aging male Heroes you
can shoot them very economically and you
can get all kinds of known Talent
um who can be in those films you can
shoot them for a day or two and you have
this big celebrity you have on the
poster but those same scripts they work
at very low budget levels but they also
work at much bigger budget levels the
genre is what's important I wouldn't do
a horror film but you could do a
Creature Feature something with some
kind of a tangible
visual thing and not just sort of the
standard issue sort of slasher film and
then I'm I'm personally a big fan of
like
tween girl romance films those do
extraordinarily well both as movies and
as well as TV series there's a lot of
latitude in those genres you can work in
so those are the things that I think
writers need to think about is these are
the genres that are going to sell I call
them Gold Mine genres that's not like an
industry term but it's uh those are the
genres that sell so if you're writing in
those buckets
uh you're writing what the industry
depends on through good times bad times
inflation non-inflation periods and uh
that's what the industry builds itself
on
and forgive me why not horror horror is
just horror and comedy are just really
really really hard to pull off I I call
these latitudes of failure which again
is not like an industry term it's just
something I made up but it's um
it's like
if you're going to write something or
shoot something if you're going to make
a movie on spec whatever it is there are
certain genres that like you gotta nail
it or it's just a dud and a comedy or a
horror film if you have like if it's 99
on point but there's like one or two
things in it that aren't ideal
uh it just like loses interest or it
loses Market placement opportunities
whereas if you have a family movie
that's very family safe if you have a
Christmas Romance movie with a dog in it
or like
a tween girl and a horse movie any of
these that like aren't
perfectly executed or there's like maybe
not the best coverage of a scene
um they still get bought and they still
get picked up and you can shoot them on
very low budgets and even if they don't
come out perfectly like there's an
audience for it because television
networks and VOD platforms around the
world love that stuff their Advertiser
safe their their very family co-viewing
friendly uh I mean Christmas movies are
a good example I don't think many people
actually watch them but they're just
like background fill and people like to
have them on and so there's not a whole
lot of dedication to the viewership of
them outside of a select group of people
so it's um but networks love them
because they really turn in the ratings
so that's the kind of thinking you have
to have is if you're going for a genre
like comedy or horror I'm not saying
don't do it I'm saying like
work on it but maybe don't have it be
your out of a gate project but you're
trying to sort of get an agent with
there's always outliers of course
there's always examples people can cite
of like well this person did it and that
person did it and it's like yeah they
did but the vast majority of people
that's not going to be the path they
follow
from your first book writing for the
green light you talk about how so many
screenwriters devour screenwriting books
and they learn structure and format but
they don't learn what to do once they've
finished that screenplay yeah it's it's
that used to drive me nuts I would say
that book specifically I wrote it
because
um it it was the book that like was
never written that I always wish sort of
existed in some capacity uh most of
those books like I think was it Sid
field who wrote he wrote screenplay it
was like that was the one that really
kick-started the whole three act
structure it was
this amazing book about how to structure
a script and how to like organize ideas
and I know there's some outdated things
in it today but like at the very end of
it there's like five pages that's an
exaggeration but there's like this like
very thin chapter at the end that's just
like oh yeah you know and go get an
agent and do those things and it's like
they'll take care of it I guess that's
the critical thing is
a lot of people write a script uh and
they just sort of expect that that's all
they need to do and um somebody else
will sort of carry it from there and
getting an agent or a manager isn't
necessarily the answer to that problem
agents and managers are great I don't
think you actually need one when you're
starting out that's my personal opinion
that's not like advice but it's it's my
personal opinion is I work with writers
who don't have agents all the time they
manage themselves
um they uh are able to just sort of
present themselves well and use their
own ability to get the door open so to
speak they have a great personal
branding that they've done on their own
online they're extraordinarily
professional they make opportunities
happen for themselves because they go
out there and they cold email they cold
call and they initiate opportunities for
themselves they're willing to Showcase
their work before just demanding that
they get paid up front when we've never
done business before obviously everybody
gets paid for their work but it's it's
sort of um sometimes you have to show
your goods in order to Showcase like I'm
the real deal and I can I can do this so
that's us
you know I I guess overall that's sort
of the the general kind of flow is you
have to be able to um
do it on your own you have to be able to
get your talents presented
on your own
and is that how they reach your door so
to speak is through a cold email
I mean that's one way to do it I mean
it's it's I've I've personally I've
worked with people who are referred I've
worked with people yeah who've shown up
uh
um via email via LinkedIn by any number
of sources who've just reached out to us
uh uh uh sort of directly just saying
like look I've I've written romance
books and I'd like to write movies or
I've written a ton of movies and I'd
like to keep that going and you know
they just sort of yeah approach it that
way it's the answer is It ultimately yes
it's they're just reaching out blindly
they're reaching out blindly but it's
not like they're reaching out with
random projects they're reaching out
with projects that sort of fit our core
expectation what we work with and they
um are just sort of showcasing like look
this is what I do I have these scripts
will you take a look at them can we do
something and we've hired a lot of
writers that way
and they are realistic that like the
first log line they present isn't going
to turn into a green light like it does
sort of have to build a bit in terms of
the relationship
so that's a real old style of thinking
maybe that I need this agent or manager
to walk me through the door yeah look a
lot I mean
again this is my personal opinion so I
mean I'm not a full disclosure like I'm
not giving career advice it's just in a
general sense it's like
um you have to think about what do
agents actually do
agents are actually in the business of
blocking opportunities by putting up
paywall
so they are restricting your access in a
way and trying to get the highest price
possible they're not out there trying to
make sure that every one of their
writers are constantly getting work
they'll sign a group of writers and then
if two out of ten are like hey people
really like their work they're going to
put all their attention on those two out
of ten and they're going to make sure
that those deals are really really
successful in those and they'll let the
others you know if you are generating
look I know a lot of writers who have
written independently and then they go
get an agent their agent I call you know
they get involved and they start hiking
prices to unrealistic levels and then we
just sort of stop working with them
because the price expectations no longer
match the budget where we're working
we're not saying that they're not
talented and that you know you shouldn't
expect reasonable compensation for your
efforts but
you can't go from like here to there in
terms of pricing overnight just because
you signed somebody and they want their
15 or whatever it just doesn't
realistically work that way so those
writers we've actually stopped working
with we've had other writers who've
gotten an agent and then they got rid of
their agent and they said you know what
I'm just going to do it independently
because I was out there getting my own
deals creating my own opportunities I
was making you know writing five six
seven movies a year at this price point
why should I give this agent you know X
percentage for just basically having
their name on my screenplay when they
did nothing they didn't initiate the
work they didn't initiate the
opportunity they didn't close the deal
so we've had a lot of writers who
actually have stepped away from their
agents and come over and just manage
themselves they just have a website uh
their own social media outlets and they
just sort of initiate the deals on their
own they go to the markets by themselves
Etc
right so similar to actors who say you
know my agent's not getting me any work
and you know but they weren't maybe
doing things behind the scenes to get
work
you know correct yeah look I mean
like it's it's the frustrating reality
of any industry like it's not isolated
to Hollywood it's it's it we just know
it it's easier to see here because you
know it's it's it's a creative driven
industry Etc but it's like
uh if you are writing a script and you
want to get your script in front of
people you have to do it yourself
just because you wrote it and it's
sitting there as a PDF on your computer
uh that's not going to get
an offer presented to you by email it's
it's you have to go put it out there and
then the first thing people are going to
do is find every reason in the world why
they shouldn't read your script because
they got 50 scripts to read that week
and they are look if if you don't have
that online presence if you don't have a
personal relationship if you haven't
been referred to them or if you haven't
present if if you write a blind email
but you present yourself well you
explain why you wrote what you wrote
um that can get attention like the
company I'm working for now
we produce very specific types of films
we do Christmas romance films we do
really cozy female driven romances in
really beautiful gorgeous locations like
very clear-cut kind of movies and so if
somebody's pitching you know some horror
film or some avant-garde
Coming of Age story like we're not going
to look at it it just doesn't fit what
we need we're looking for stuff that's
going to keep our pipeline going but
when people come out and they're like
hey I can write Christmas romances and I
have here's the script and 10 log lines
of Christmas romances
we'll take a look at it and we've
actually bought a few of those
and then you have a few you said women
in Peril so like these Thrillers I saw
one like some kind of cyber stalking or
something yeah yeah we do we do women
apparel Thrillers as well like very
lifetime kind of films
um they're
we don't do as many of those like I
would say probably like 55 60 of our
output right now is like Christmas
romance movies It's a Wonderful bread
and butter sure sure vertical yeah I
love what you said too about just some
people just want to have them on in the
background yeah and I think that's very
true and it it lends to the season like
if you want to feel the season having it
on in the background it the plot doesn't
even matter at times yeah I mean it's
just it's a plus I kind of recycled a
bit too but uh yeah it's it but it's
kind of like that Yuletide log you know
when it was just like an hour video of a
fireplace burning you know and it was
just uh people would put it on the TV
and it had the Crackle Pop sound and the
visual and it felt like the holidays and
yes that's absolutely transferred into
the holiday films it's
I've been doing I've been in the TV
movie world for over 10 years and that's
never changed that the volume of content
has actually gotten bigger
when being pitched every executive has
this question why am I looking at this
yeah
it's uh uh
there are I think a couple of uh
questions that may never be asked that
you sort of have to be able to answer
with a pitch
um and that is definitely one of them I
think that's probably the the most
critical first one
it's
and it goes back to a lot of the other
things we've sort of been discussing
it's Executives have very limited time
and they have very specific needs that
they're looking for they need to find
content that's going to fit into very
specific slots or buckets and that's
what they need to know is it going to
fit or is it not and that's really I
think what the core of that question is
why am I looking at this does it work
for us does it fit is it in the price
point can we utilize it can we make it
something into an even bigger
opportunity Etc
but yeah they want to know
how is this serving what we're trying to
do
and should the writer then try to put
themselves in that executive shoes and
question why would they want to look at
this or writers blind to that because
they think that their material is is the
answer I mean should we kind of question
why would this executive meet with me
I think if if you have an opportunity to
meet with
a production company executive
distribution executive anyone in that
World
um I I wouldn't question it I would just
sort of utilize it as an opportunity of
how how can my what what what can I do
with my talents and help serve what
you're trying to do in a way uh reason I
say that is not to in any way not be
true to what you want to write or what
you want to create but more
what do I have to do to make my script
work for what you're trying to achieve
here or what can I write to help you
know your company mandate or expectation
of growth
um you got to think of like businesses
sort of like systems it's
it's you know it's it's a collection of
small things that they're all trying to
do in order to like just grow grow they
need films they have money to spend and
they have to spend it on movies they
have spent it on movies that are already
completed they have to spend it on
movies that are not yet completed but
are in development so that they can
satisfy their client base so they have
Deep Pockets not
you know not bottomless Pockets but they
do have money to spend
and they're only going to spend it on so
many movies what you need to do is
really figure out okay if you're only
going to spend it on so many movies how
can I make mine be the one that's going
to work and
having a mindset of like zero
concessions and not being a team player
is not going to make that happen but
being able to say here's a couple of
ideas do one of these resonate and then
if it can you know sort of be tweaked
and you know molded a bit and pruned
here and there then it can sort of start
to fit into something that will work not
just for the Distribution Company but
their client who's trying to feed into
an audience or an end user
would you say most of the writers that
reach out to you without representation
they've researched the genres that they
should be pitching you it's not like
it's a total non-match uh it's in truth
it's probably more like 50 50.
um
and
if if I'm if our company is getting I
don't know
50 emails let's say and 25 are just like
I'm I wrote a script about XYZ that has
nothing to do with what you guys do
um you know we'll just politely decline
before we even
we'll just we'll just say no and that's
that's assuming you know we you know
it's yeah it's usually just kind of a
it's not going to work for us we it you
know it's we're not we're not in that
business
um but if it is something that is sort
of dabbling into the world where we work
we'll take a look at it
now taking a look at it doesn't mean
that we're gonna buy it or do business
together in the immediate future but it
is an opportunity to sort of
plant a seed and figure something out
down the road
but yeah I mean we've worked with
writers who've reached out to us blindly
and their initial scripts none of them
were that first thing that got made but
it showed us like okay this person
actually knows how to write the genre
well and then when an opportunity comes
up we have reached out to them and said
like would you write this and they say
yes we do our deal and they get paid we
deliver the script everyone's happy and
we've done that with a couple writers
and then there's a few others that um
you know we're on good relations with
where we they have the right scripts but
um we just haven't found that project
yet to work on together uh but I know
that we will because it's just we have
already established that sort of
communication and it's just a matter of
time till we sort of figure out like
okay this will work really well for that
writer because every writer has their
own style too
what is a verifiable audience
um verifiable audience is something that
it's it's a way of describing
a guaranteed viewer of content
um
a legitimate audience of people out
there that you can sort of Bank on or
project upon so what I mean by that is
like if you have a book
um whomever purchased the book would be
a verifiable audience those are people
out there who actually transacted on it
they bought it so they must have had
some kind of interest in it and if you
were to make a movie on that book you
could use that verifiable audience to
sort of project the types of viewers you
would likely have or the types of
outlets you could likely go to it's also
if you think about you know ratings
systems in terms of viewership metrics
that would also be verifiable audience
it's sort of people who
uh are actually interacting with your
content engaging with it
um you're able to sort of look at that
audience as a core Define who they are
and uh be able to sort of say if we're
going to be making a project like this
or in this space who would our
verifiable audience be to reach out to
now in a pitch capacity if you are
trying to sort of bring an idea to the
table to pitch it you would need to
Showcase that your projects have a
verifiable audience this is I think
where it gets a little bit wonky for
people who are sort of new to the
industry because they love to sort of
take outlier projects meaning examples
of movies from the past that were
extremely successful
and you know that we're sort of
not representative of the average but
sort of like those Mega hits that were
like unexpected big hit films or TV
shows or whatever those are the ones I
like to quote a lot but verifiable
audience is actually more of the sort of
boring average it's sort of the
predictable expectation I think the
thing people talk about with Star Wars
for instance the original one way back
in the 70s
um George Lucas said I'm getting my
numbers wrong I haven't thought about
this example in over a decade but it's I
think he was saying at the time an
average movie of that style made about
15 16 million dollars at the box office
so if they could make their movie at
around 10 million they it was going to
be a success obviously like the massive
success of that and what it launched was
never expected by anybody I don't even
think by
George Lucas himself but that kind of
thinking that if we make the move if
there's an audience that repeatedly
watches this kind of content what money
does that generate how do we quantify
that
um where do they watch it and how do we
calculate that out and then if you find
that average you can sort of work your
way backwards too okay well then what
movie do we need to make how much does
it need to cost what kind of cast do we
need to populate it with and that's sort
of the process
how does a beginning writer know their
story has a verifiable audience
I think if you're working with an
original story idea
um it's it's sticking to the sort of
Gold Miner core genres I talk about a
lot
because those are sort of the tried and
tested and proven
you know buckets of programming that are
always in need
so if you are writing a movie in that
space whether it's a tween girl romance
or you know a female driven Thriller
um one of those titles one of those
projects you know you're speaking to a
core group of a core demographic I'll
say of audience that likes and responds
to that it resonates with them now
there's so many granular sort of details
within all that
but that's sort of the beginning point
is if you're sticking to a core genre or
a gold mine genre then at least you know
you're sort of in the right
building so to speak as you get deeper
into it
um I'm not saying write cliches I'm
obviously I'm very against cliches but
it's it's you do need to use you need to
be very true to what that genre is
um so if that's certain types of
character combinations if that's certain
types of story arcs
um that I think is really those are sort
of the the metrics of
am I sort of in the right Zone here and
if you have that down uh I think you're
sort of in the right ballpark so to
speak that's if you're just doing it
totally original work that's and you're
starting from the very beginning of I'm
going to create a story here I'd follow
that mindset of work backwards what does
the industry need what do television
channels need what do VOD platforms need
and what is going to help them grow
audience and sustain it and think about
it at an independent level not at Big
mega million per episode or or you know
multi-million dollar film level I'm
thinking more like a smaller scale low
budget movie under 2 million budget if
you're thinking more at that scale
that's where the real volume is that a
lot of companies work within
that represents the vast majority of
what gets produced every single year on
a global basis and if you're sort of
working in that and you're working in
the core genres you're sort of feeding
into that pipeline of what's needed
can you give me some examples of a
cliche
a couple cliches that uh
truth is like you just sort of know them
when you see him it's it's the expected
it's the it's the I mean there's so many
jokes I mean look I work in Christmas
movies like it's so many jokes about you
know
big city girl who uh uh you know just is
having tough time in the city on her own
her perfect life uh doesn't work so she
goes back to her small town you know
these are the that's your cliche and
then of course she reunites with so and
so who she used to know as a kid and
then there's some friction and then like
you know they hit it off in the end and
everything's perfect and it's a perfect
Christmas so for like a Christmas
Romance
um that is sort of the cliche of the
storyline but that structure does work
so you have to find your
differences within that structure and
this is this is actually where the
talent of writing comes in where it's
it's so easy to like poke fun at that
and say anybody can write those things
anybody can write a tween girl romance
film anybody can write a girl in a
Horrors film try it do it like it's it's
harder than it looks and the amount of
creative meetings I've had on that
storyline on how to make it different
how to make it unique how to maintain an
audience that needs to see that but keep
them engaged so they don't feel like
they're seeing the same thing they've
already seen it's a lot harder than it
looks and there's a lot more involved
development discussions and creative
meetings than you would ever expect
from the very beginning all the way
through pre-production all the way
through the editing process
so it's it's when you're trying to reach
a core verifiable audience it's going
back to Christmas movies because it's an
obvious one
there's hundreds that get made every
single year like you're speaking to an
audience like there's a verifiable
audience and there's metrics from
Lifetime and Hallmark and all of them
that you know they make a certain number
of films every single year
um and it goes back to how do you get
your foot in the door well you think
about if they're going to spend all this
money which they're going to I guarantee
you they're already working on their
2024 slates
um how do you augment your work so that
you're the one they spend money on and
it's sort of looking at that and saying
all right that's the tried and tested
expectation that's the genre there's
clearly a verifiable audience for it now
how do I find those subtle differences
that make the structure work uh that
that aren't the same old boring cliche
it's it's it's the classic like the same
thing only different
yeah because I've noticed that a lot of
these films and I think this works it's
somebody returns back to the small
Hometown and they're either met with
open arms or met with resistance but
there's something about that that seems
like it's satisfying to viewers yeah
yeah and look we we've done it the other
way we've had the small town go to the
big city we've had the whole thing take
place in the big city we've had the
whole thing take place in a small town
we've had it be that um it's it's the
lead characters dealing with a loss they
lost a a spouse or a mother or somebody
who is very close to them and so they
are feeling that separation but it's
emotional instead of like physical we uh
we we we're just doing a movie now
um we just wrapped on it and it's about
somebody who returns home but not
because she wants to she's doing it
because she's basically uh at a
Crossroads with her job and she's going
to go home to her small town and
actually
exploit something about her small town
for work to return to the big city her
intention is to go back to the big city
City and she's just utilizing the
opportunity to go there and do something
but of course while she's there she
realizes that she can't do this and
everything's happy in the end but um
it's the intention was very very
different than the same old like so I
guess that motivation of how do you end
up from point A to point B that's it's
those subtle things that sort of make a
script or a story pop and it's a writer
who can deliver unique variations of
that
um
very consistently but like you know
bring something new to the table that
fits the mold every time
that's sort of how it works sure and it
seems like those genres also uh
transcend different age groups as well
they certainly do they certainly do
um
I think Mysteries is sort of a good one
that would fall more into like your
female driven Thriller but uh Mysteries
can can really be you know you can have
your old lady Mysteries you can have
your you know young fresh audience
Mysteries there's whole series of books
that are aimed at tween readers that are
Mysteries
um so that's definitely a genre that
sort of satisfies a very wide spectrum
but you can have sub-genres within it
that sort of focus on one demographic at
a time yeah
you believe there are seven core
principles to pitching yeah and I like
to use the word principle instead of
rules because uh truth is like
I mean you can see in the past like 15
years in the past three years in in
terms of how things have worked just how
things technology interactions the way
we engage with content that changes all
the time
but the core principles behind how
things function those never change so I
like to work with principals yeah but I
I've identified
seven that I think are just sort of true
and consistent they're the same today as
they were back in Shakespeare's time
period of how do you pitch a story idea
and get the thing rolling well it looks
like the first one is selling yes okay I
think sales has a really negative word
or connotation I should say to it but
you have to sell yourself
if you want to pitch your idea
we talked about it before you can you
can write a great script but if it just
sits on your desktop on your laptop like
no one's going to see it you need to be
able to pitch yourself you need to be
able to pitch why it's worth reading you
need to get it to the right people not
get it to everybody not do a mass email
but find the right people the right
companies that would resonate with it
and sell yourself and sell your idea
number two pitching is listening
pitching is listening yes
um
I most of my pitch meetings because I
pitch two you know I'm pitching business
to business so I'm pitching
a business opportunity of how can we get
a film made how can we get a TV series
made in order for me to get that order
out of the client I need to listen to
what they want they need to tell me
um either they need to tell me or I need
to do the research and find out what is
it that they need what are they looking
for what is their company on the hunt
for and I have to Showcase why we're the
best ones to deliver it and if you're
pitching your ideas uh
your stack of of 100 pages of script
like that doesn't change in the middle
of that meeting but how you talk about
it can so if um you're dealing with a
client and they start presenting or
discussing or describing content in a
specific way listening to that listening
to how they talk about content listening
to what it is that they really need is
your way to transition a meeting into an
opportunity for yourself so yeah it's
people will tell you exactly what they
need they'll tell you exactly what they
want and there's no shortage of
information out there in terms of being
able to at least get a pretty solid idea
of how to position yourself what if
they're so nervous that they can't
listen because they're so worried about
will this turn out do they like my work
whatever it is look it's it's it can be
nerve-wracking in a sense like I would
say this actually it can be
nerve-wracking when you're not used to
it
um it can be nerve-wracking when you
have built this idea of what pitching
must be like versus how it actually is I
think most people Envision uh you know
an Entourage scary boardroom situation
of you know six seven eight
expensive suit people staring at you
with like cold faces and um
I'm not saying I haven't had that
experience but like for the most part
pitching is actually pretty easy going
you're meeting somebody over coffee
you're having just a quick chat over a
zoom or you know a Google meeting
um phone call
that's how most pitching is actually
most pitching is done by email and if
you are uncomfortable
you can take as much time as you need to
craft a good email and if you can Target
it well and you don't write it too long
you know you can actually sort of pitch
quite well that way but you always want
to make it more that look I'm starting
this idea but I'm really here to work
for you what do you need as a company
because I can deliver it and that's sort
of the opportunity to get that feedback
loop of we need XYZ and we need writers
who can work in this capacity
and excuse me how long is too long for
an email uh yeah they've actually done
studies on this I'm sure there's some
analysis somewhere
um but and I think there's actually like
studies about how long you should I
think it's like 27 characters for a
subject line so it can be read entirely
on an iPhone uh
but anyway that's a whole long-winded
way that's fascinating I would say like
four paragraphs of like two sentences
each is like the max for an email and
it's Gotta sort of be
you're presenting everything you've got
you know the five W's who what where
when why it's you're saying this is who
I am this is the script I have and you
got to make it as easy for your client
as possible when I'm pitching movies
they're finished movies but when I'm
pitching movies
um to buyers internationally or here in
the states like I make it as easy for
them as possible because they're busy
and it's not that they're rude it's not
that they're you know it's just that
they're busy so the easier I can make it
the better
um
you're presenting yourself you know you
want to talk about yourself it's not
don't just dive in with screenplays XYZ
this is the concept it's much more like
you know you've showcased that you've
actually like done your research and
that you're presenting yourself and by
the way you have this script too and
you'd like to start a conversation about
writing you know it's it's not like buy
this script right now it's much more
I I'm a writer I'm trying to look for uh
opportunities what you're writing I'm
sorry what you're producing is very much
in sync with what I'm writing I have a
couple of log lines I'd love to share
them with you if uh you know we can chat
sometime it's it's very casual number
three presentation matters absolutely
um
most of the deals I have secured it's
what I do in the industry I'm selling
things that don't exist I'm going into
uh a television network or working with
a VOD platform and I am selling as I
said a lot of the deals I do the
contract is literally like title to be
determined we have no idea what the
movie is we're selling that we're going
to make a movie and sometimes it'll be
like to be determined Christmas movie or
to be determined Thriller but we don't
know what the movie is
um so in order to get that I have to
present in the best possible manner uh
what it is that I'm going to deliver
upon so if you are doing that so I mean
I'll create like really nice pitch decks
I'll spend a lot of time on them
um I'll I'll Source images from places
like canva or pixel or other or other
spots and they have these amazing
resources the photos you can use and you
can build presentations our whole
industry and I think in a visual minded
sense a lot of those on the creative
side in our industry are very visual
thinking so being able to express their
ideas in a visual way I think is
important
uh and they also get to do that after
doing like a personal branding website
but that's sort of the thing I guess I'm
talking about is
if if a name pops up uh in an email
um in somebody's email box like before
you hit reply you're gonna like Google
them
or is this person legit is this spam is
this this is this that and um looking if
they have a website
if they if they don't have credits
that's okay uh but it's like if they
have a website and you can see like this
is a real person and they seem to be
very professional and they seem to sort
of like be reasonable and how they're
functioning in terms of what their
expectations are yeah you will probably
reach out you don't want to lose an
opportunity
um and presentation matters in the sense
of how you dress how do you present
yourself how what is your etiquette when
you're on the phone or or via email are
you clear and do you do you express
yourself clearly or are you one of these
people who just like has really choppy
vague emails and people aren't really
sure what to make of them do you over
extend the opportunity and reach too far
too quickly
um
it's it's those are kinds of the things
about presentation matters but I think
website visual what can you do there's a
lot of that is in your own control too
and I think that's actually something
that's good
and just curious what would an example
be of overextending oh like like 9 000
emails a day or you know way too many
text messages I mean I have people who
like
send me like 15 text messages in a row
like it's like
my phone just vibrates for a good like
12 seconds and I know who it is you know
it's uh it's people like that that's a
little bit overreaching too many phone
calls but the occasional like check-in
is totally fine and you should check in
and like keep up on things but um you
know it's it's I think basic etiquette
understanding so maybe the understanding
of realizing that you're not the only
person they're working with I know it's
hard when it comes to your personal
matter or project but realizing this
person might be dealing with a hundred
emails that day yeah it's it's for sure
and look I mean 100 is a good day like I
I get way more than that and um you
can't read them all you can't read them
all so you do have to like make
decisions of like what am I gonna
actually focus on today and getting to
some of those kinds of emails that are
more like the blind cold call cold email
kind of things
it is at the bottom of the list but it
does get addressed and so that's why
it's so important like if you've got
that much time
and that much attention from somebody
you got to make sure you're you're
getting everything right that's
presentation that you've done your
research that you're presenting stuff
that actually resonates you know and
it's it's that's sort of where all that
falls into and yeah I think it's it's
really critical to remember that when
you're reaching out and I I remind
myself of this too
because like
it'll go weeks and I won't hear back
from clients and
um you know you sort of do question like
you know what what went wrong and the
truth is they're busy they're really
busy they and they have personal lives I
have a personal life I have a family you
know it's it's um that does eat into the
equation too in terms of time
number four pitching is repitching yeah
it's it's it's
um it's not like you pitch once and then
everything just falls into place it's um
you will pitch your idea at log line
stage and if you're fortunate enough to
get
um a writer for higher agreement you'll
repitch the ideas you put in the
treatment you'll have to repitch at
script at script stage you'll have to
once the script is acquired I have to go
pitch people I have to go pitch people
to get the project funded we have to go
pitch it to talent and explain to them
why they would want to be in this film
you would think that you know actors
would be jumping up and down to be in
movies but it's like
um sometimes they are so busy with
projects you also have to pitch like
look if you can only do seven films this
year this should be one of them and
here's why and it's it's a constant
thing when we're marketing our films
that's a pitch a trailer of a movie is a
pitch it's pitching you saying you only
have so much time this evening to watch
a television show or a movie make it
ours
Pluto TV uh Tubi TV Netflix they're
pitching you too and they're saying if
you only are going to watch content on
one platform tonight make it us that
that's the whole process of repitching
this it's not like you do it once and
it's done if you take a film like
Chinatown which just for some reason is
just constantly said is like the best
script ever written and it's like that's
not actually what it was when they
filmed the movie that's what it ended up
being in the end
um but you know at script stage that had
to get you know that had to go through a
lot of layers before it finally turned
out the other side at the end the way it
did and a lot of that also happened on
set in the editing room and just you
know uh uh concessions they had to make
in post and all that so it's it's that
sort of the thinking is that
a script is never done until the movie
is released that's sort of my view of it
number five pitching is a slow process
yes it's a very slow process it does not
happen overnight I'm I'm talking to it's
it's right now it's March 2023 when
we're filming this I'm pitching clients
you know uh uh 18 months in advance in
the sense of I'm trying to to guarantee
slates that are next year or even early
2025.
um it's it's a slow process in the sense
of
you may have to pitch a client and then
repitch them and then repitch them and
then repitch them market after market
quarter after court quarter I try to get
um usually quarterly calls or like you
know six month calls with some of my key
clients just to keep them up to speed of
what we're doing and what we can bring
to the table
um and yeah we are constantly
representing sometimes the same stuff in
those meetings uh I would say on average
like to get a movie like a low budget
movie anything under two and a half
million
um
that can be
kind of quick you could do that maybe in
six months like concept to green light
but if you're talking television like a
whole series that's at least an 18-month
process if not two years and that's
planting the seed of the idea and then
like this is why I always Focus so much
on principles over Trends because there
are Trends there are things that are
like super popular today and then you'll
get a flood of emails from writers who
like I stayed up all night and wrote
this movie because this is like the hot
new thing and it's like it's gonna take
like six months to get this funded shot
delivered released by that time that
trend is gone nobody cares about it
anymore so it's it's TV shows that come
out and they're extremely like relevant
or everyone's talking about it they were
just really good quality programs but
they were being developed you know 18
months two years uh beforehand I mean
Queen's Gambit is like the best example
I don't know the exact dates of that one
but I want to say it was like the 90s
the early like they started they
greenlit I'm sorry they acquired the
book rights before the lead actress was
even born like that's how long that was
in that development hell process it's a
very slow process and the truth is you
got to keep a lot of pots boiling at
once on the back burner you know if I'm
dealing with a client and they need six
films this year I may have 18 to 20
projects we're keeping warm
because we don't know exactly which one
they're going to go with and then they
pick them very quick and then all of a
sudden you're Off to the Races but yeah
that that process in between can be a
very long drawn out time period
number six pitching is a lot like dating
yes this is this is a
I adamantly believe that business in
general is a lot like dating it's um you
use the exact same protocols you are
putting yourself out there you have kind
of a clear understanding of what you're
trying to achieve and there's no exact
one way to get from beginning to end so
to speak you do have to presentation
matters you do have to sort of pitch and
present who you are you have to sort of
showcase why you're worth dating uh you
have to bring all that to the table you
have to be willing to go out and accept
that some people are going to say no and
they were going to say no no matter what
you said you're just not compatible the
chemistry isn't right and then the whole
process of how do you communicate
um you know you don't want to over
communicate you don't want to write too
many crazy emails you don't want to text
too much you don't want to call
inappropriate numbers of times or leave
50 voicemails all of those little sort
of nuances I think are just true of
human behavior in general you there's
sort of a social understanding of
this is an acceptable mode of how we're
communicating and then there's kind of a
a totally Unwritten line that you sort
of instinctually know you shouldn't
cross but unfortunately a few people do
and uh that's sort of where that all
comes from so if we took that analogy
and said well okay don't talk about your
ex on the first date for like over an
hour
what would be the same thing for a
writer maybe don't talk about deals that
fell through and trash a studio or what
would be the same type of thing because
that's an equal turn off you know yeah I
would say just in general
don't talk anybody like and and
like just
I'm not even gonna say like it's okay if
like the other person brings it up like
just don't don't be that person be
professional it's okay that you have a
script that you know was with another
client and maybe they optioned it and
then nothing happened with it that
happens and that does not make it like a
tarnished property
um
you can you can speak openly but you
don't have to like you know you don't
want to trash talk people and and fall
into that game uh that just because the
the question always then ends up being
like well if things don't work out with
us what are you going to say about us
behind our backs you know so it's like
it kind of makes people kind of want to
say I don't know if I really want to
bring this writer in because uh
they what are they going to say if like
if if they write a script for us and we
pay them and then like all of a sudden
the network says no to the project and
they get the rights to the script back
they've been paid but um you know these
things happen and so yeah if you have
writers who sort of like you know trash
talk people that does happen
um so it's those kinds of things it's
just again it's like it's it's basic
social skills basic etiquette
number seven relationships are
everything yes relationships
um really fuel the business
uh and that's I think the most
challenging at first it feels the most
challenging I would say if you're new to
the industry
um
regardless of what age you are it's it's
just uh if you're new to the industry it
feels like you know nobody and I would
say like during the pandemic
this was so powerfully understood
because those of us who've been in the
industry long enough you know
10 years 15 years who have real clients
that we know and can reach out to
we were fine during the pandemic we
could communicate we should just reach
out and shoot an email or a call and it
was fine but if you didn't have those
connections that was such a tough time
period and it really
kind of created this big gap and I know
a lot of younger people who are kind of
maybe a year or two behind where they
could be because of the pandemic but um
where do you meet connections and how do
you build them truth is you just start
you don't you just start one at a time
and it's okay to talk to people and meet
with people who don't seem to have
anything to do with what you do and in
truth that's where you're going to find
your Best Contacts like if you are a
writer it's great to work with other
writers and talk to other writers but at
a certain point like you also need to
meet people on the other side of the
fence who are more on the business side
and learn what they do and learn how
they function in their system so that
you can sort of find those opportunities
but it's just a slow process it's it's
not going to happen overnight and it's
something you just sort of have to make
a habit you have to make a habit of
talking to other people you have to make
a habit of communicating well presenting
yourself well all the time and it goes
back to the whole pitching is like
dating it's like
if you are single you know those
opportunities can pop up at any time so
you sort of have to always be ready for
them I guess in a sense but yeah it's
it's you need to be able to consistently
and regularly
be open to the idea of communicating
with people who are in the industry
learn what they do find out how it works
in the system and if you just kind of
keep that process going and you stay in
relatively reasonable communication with
everybody over time you'll start to find
dots to connect I know that person and
they are at that company and I can reach
out to them now and maybe when you first
met that wasn't the case but you know 12
months down the line they got a job
opportunity and now it's an in for you
that's how it works and then once you do
work together
and you've gotten a job or two in
whatever capacity in the industry you
just do the best work you can and Truth
is like your reputation does hold and
it's the little things that give people
a sense of who you really are so you got
to give it your all do you feel like
writers expect things to happen more
rapidly as the world has gotten so fast
and everything's instantaneous have you
noticed that or no that's yes I think in
general uh
uh it's it's a sense that people have
that like things just
happen way quicker than they really do
you know that if you if you send a
script that it's going to be read that
day or the next day and it's like you
know it may take a month to get it read
uh if if there is a deal to be done
um that it's going to happen in a week
and it's like no it can take two three
months to negotiate a deal uh so it it
just draws out a lot longer on the
actual real world professional side and
so that will Ripple into buying cycles
and scripts
um but yeah I think it's it's being
realistic about time expectations is
very critical to anyone starting out in
the industry in whatever capacity
what is a gold mine genre it's a phrase
I made up so it's not like a it's not
like an industry term but it's um uh
it's I I call them gold mines because
they are just core genres that through
good times and bad times
have been and as far as I can possibly
see will always be in need year on year
in the entertainment industry so it's
just basic buckets of genres that for
whatever reason you know for the past
several hundred years whether in book
form stage play and now movies and TV
shows they just hit a certain audience
that's large enough to keep momentum
moving so if those genres if if they're
seen by a Distribution Company a
production company a studio
they always sort of take them a little
bit more seriously than something that
doesn't fit easily into that uh and and
budget is sort of you know doesn't
really apply it's they can be extremely
low budget they can be extremely big
budget but it's more just what kind of
film is it is it a female driven
Thriller is it a Christmas uh romance uh
is it something along those those
categories that just fits perfectly with
what the industry needs year on year how
many gold mine genres are there uh I I
say six
um
I mean you can you can dive a little bit
deeper than that but I mean it really
kind of fits into six there's Christmas
uh there is uh female driven Thriller
there is tween girl
uh there's sort of
I I call it like the Aging male action
hero film uh there's creature features
and then there are
um I'd call it like
boy family safe but boy driven adventure
story so that'd be like your treasure
Hunters uh kind of uh Spy Kids kind of
thing
um you know creature features those are
kind of self-evident and those range
from like Sharknado to like very high
budgeted Hollywood films uh your aging
male action uh hero film on the extreme
low budget these are movies that are
shot like for less than a million and a
half or two million dollars but they
have like Jean-Claude Van Damme or Dolph
Lundgren for like one day on set and
they're like The Mastermind boss at a
desk and they edit it so it appears you
know scattered throughout the film but
the key thing is that they get to be on
the poster
um Christmas movies they're self-evident
if you can throw in a dog that's great
the tween girl films
um
I really like them when they have a
horse in them or if they have some kind
of animal a part of it those also work
with Christmas I think Christmas dog
movies work well uh Christmas and a
horse that absolutely fits the season if
you have a nice snowy background and all
um and then uh yeah it's it's they just
work consistently and you'll see them
like once you kind of categorize it like
that you'll see them every year
big Studio films down to like
microscopic microscopic budgetedly
titles like you'll see them those are
the ones that just Hollywood
consistently needs you see lots of
comedies you see lots of horror that
stuff is usually developed the other way
around which means that um a studio is
trying to promote a big comedy Talent
uh and like Comedy Central worked like
this for a long time so if you have
somebody like an Amy Schumer you know
they start they identified her and they
sort of started they kind of dabbled a
bit by testing with like well let's do
some one hour specials and see how that
does okay the audience is there it works
let's maybe put them in a movie or
something and you see that with a lot of
Comedy Talent it follows that kind of
pattern so they're not like it's not
like somebody wrote the script and then
uh the studio Executives just went wow
this is great let's get this talent to
put it's the opposite way around they're
trying to build a giant brand Around
Talent and promote that talent in their
career and horror is very different
horror is uh such a Fickle genre it's um
you need to nail it and it's it's the
audience is so specific with horror and
the attributes that that
um will land a horror film are very
different than other genres like who the
director is is is critical in horror uh
and sometimes so it kind of comes since
the the director or some key aspect of
the genre is actually what keeps the
audience engaged or interested uh some
of the creative ideas actually have to
come from that Source out and then it
Maps out so those are I think those are
just really hard ones to enter into and
then just like standard issue dramas
like
they're just boring they they require so
much talent to uh sell it and that
Talent is so expensive it just makes it
really complicated
when you're talking about some of the
movies that most screenwriters would be
sort of hired for it would be like just
sort of one protagonist correct yeah
it's it's
um
you got to think of it like barriers to
entry uh you know not to use too much
like business jargon in this kind of
setting but I mean I think screenwriters
if you're if you're going to be starting
a career you need to think about it as a
career in an industry
um and I think that the easiest point of
entry is yeah focusing on the one
protagonist story you can have your B
plot you should but um it's really got
to follow that one protagonist on his or
her journey usually her it's it's I
think I think there's a much larger
female audience in general or a much
larger need of content for female
audiences so I think having a
protagonist be female is is pretty
critical in whatever genre you focus on
let's take the movie with Rob
the dog movie
but there's also the Channing Tatum one
that's it's a dog movie too it's uh it's
a great vehicle yeah but women like
uh
uh they are they it is it is an
attractive story to have
um a guy with a dog uh that combo can
actually be quite appealing they've done
a lot of dating studies on this
apparently
sure sure absolutely what about a guy
with a cat this is quite it doesn't
quite nail it the same way I mean what
if it's an exotic cat okay yeah and then
we've I think I've definitely seen the
cat film Christmas movie let's say I've
seen like the cat film tried a few times
it just doesn't land it unless the cat
because cats have such a unique
character you know why is it important
for writers to understand these genres
it's
it's important just to step back and
understand how the industry works
uh and since these are the genres that
are just consistently in need
um focusing a lot of attention on theirs
is I think pretty critical like it's
it's
if you're gonna spend all the time to
write a script and try to build a career
you might as well focus on something
that has like a higher probability of
success than something that has a lot
more barriers of you know restriction
against you uh so if you're just
focusing on these genres understanding
and being realistic that like hey this
is what real people want to watch
and choosing to write that just makes a
little bit more logical sense in terms
of like opening your doors of
opportunity
and one shouldn't think that these
genres
are you know just overly cliched or or
uh not important enough it's it's
there's so many stories you can tell
within them and it's it's you can dive
really deep into character and really
convey some amazing ideas even with
these sort of like tried and tested
genres
so I don't think they should be
dismissed I think there's a lot of
really good opportunity for writers in
them and you're talking about working
writers writers that are not on a TV
show that have a career that that make
money that support themselves from their
scripts to churn out these things it's
not just like a a one-off art film that
they're going to win a contest these are
people that you know are building a
career off this yeah yeah and these are
these are definitely career writers who
who like
the writers we work with we work with
them consistently and they churn out
scripts uh I mean I don't need to
undercut it but I mean like they can
write fast and they can deliver quickly
and you know they're writing a new
script every month maybe every two
months and they're getting paid on them
and so it's like that is a career they
built that slowly it took time to build
but they got to a point where they said
like look I can deliver tween girl
movies like really really well I can
write them very fast I can write them in
in really strong detail I can convey
some very solid uh wonderful ideas
within them I mean think about what you
can do with that you can explore so many
ideas about complications and
Adolescence stress you feel with
adolescence you can dive into mental
health issues you can dive into body
positivity you can dive into so many
facets all within like one cliched idea
and if you're going to be writing these
deep uh uh experiences or if you're
going to be writing meaningful stories
and you just put it inside the bright
shiny box of a gold mine genre like
you're gonna get noticed I'm not saying
you're gonna get the deal it's like like
you might as well do the thing that's
going to open more doors of opportunity
for you so if you do some deep
overwhelming coming-of-age story uh
that's just gonna like disappear in
somebody's inbox or if you say it's a
tween girl film and it follows it's
about so and so doing XYZ and you know
it talks about these themes because it's
a tween girl film it's going to get
opened at least by more people
where would you put Wednesday atoms
that's complicated because it is a piece
of known IP it's it's a derivative of
something we've known through a lot of
different variations the original Show
the movie variations in the 90s they've
had a couple of animated versions of it
so there already comes a bit of like a
cult identity with it so that falls into
what we talked about before in terms of
verifiable audience there's always been
a subgroup of people that respond well
to the sort of quirky dark comedies or
just films that dive deep into that uh
and then they just I guess it's maybe a
reboot slash spin-off because you're
focused on her it's sort of a weird
hybrid and Netflix gets to do this
because they have so much money
um they can really take interesting
chances but it's talent-led meaning the
creative Talent LED somebody very high
up in in some big agencies basically
came to them with the concept and
because it's a known piece of Ip you've
got a really good recipe for something
there to play with
but it is a tween girl film at the end
of the day it's following her and going
through a journey so
can you have a good meeting where
everything goes right and then the
executives reject your pitch yes you can
and it happens quite a bit actually and
those are for reasons that are
sometimes totally out of your control
um I was mentioning earlier that
sometimes even on our side we're
business to business so we're dealing
directly with presidents of networks or
or heads of channels or VOD platforms
and um
we're in a meeting and we're pitching
and presenting our slate of projects and
then uh unbeknownst to us behind closed
doors in their boardroom
they get a new mandate from the top and
all of a sudden you know metrics come in
or there's some kind of a decision at
the channel to Pivot uh in terms of
content and we find out about it later
and so the next time we have a meeting
it's either we get rejected on titles
that we were certain were going to
happen
um or we just find out that like oh you
know that that direction you were going
all in on is now no longer the case and
now going over here so even at our level
that happens and so I think it's very
important for anyone starting out in the
industry to remember that like
you can pitch something in January and
like nobody wants it and then like July
everyone's looking for that exact same
thing and it's like you know a lot of
that is you're just sort of shooting in
the dark to a degree that's why it's
important to do as much research as you
can find out the the kind of core
consistencies of what companies are
doing the general trends that networks
or VOD platforms are going for the
general buckets of content they focus on
and at least you're like kind of in the
right Zone you will never have all of
the information and so yeah you can go
in you can be on total good terms with
everybody you can you can be presenting
yourself extraordinarily well your story
could be very well received in the room
there could even be some back and forth
in terms of paperwork and then all of a
sudden last second
we're pulling away from this deal it
happens yes and I think developing a
thick skin and just accepting that and
uh being realistic about that is the
only way to battle it and just move on
to the next one and it doesn't the other
thing is critical in that is not to lose
your temper it's to stay well composed
it goes back to the other things
relationships are key uh uh it's a lot
like dating
um it's it's you need to be able in
presentation matters even I guess in
terms of uh principles of pitching like
you need to handle rejection very well
and be professional about it and
understanding if you need to like take a
day before responding that's fine but
you know always respond to it with a I
get it thanks for the opportunity Etc
because then you're keeping that
opportunity alive for the future and
guess what like those companies will
sometimes come back and say we have this
new project can you write it so if you
rejection happens it's part of the game
and can it also happen where you're in
the meeting and you get these arms
crossed and you think oh I have bombs
and I just did a horrible job and then
you hear actually that you're their
person yes this is it absolutely happens
too
um
uh
how do I say this like it's it's when
you focus on genres that are just
um the core needs you know it's uh they
know whether it works or not and like
you know these are people that get
pitched like dozens of projects A Day In
some cases I have been in meetings where
like
the guy showed up late and like was
clearly it didn't look like he was
paying attention at all and um you're
just sort of like you feel like talking
to someone who's just staring at their
phone like pitching to a teenager and
it's like
um
then all of a sudden you get that email
like a week later and it's like so you
just gotta go with it and you know you
can't control this is what I tell my
kids it's like you can't control what
other people do you just have to focus
on what you are doing and the decisions
you are making how you're presenting
yourself and making sure that you're
bringing up what you can do presenting
yourself and pitching your ideas in the
best way you have the control of doing
and that's not just in the room that's
the that's if you create a website if
you do your personal branding how will
you relax how you relate to people
online the kinds of stuff you type
online that stuff doesn't go away and
you Google enough you'll find that on
people and so it's very critical that at
all times you're conducting yourself in
the best manner you can but yeah it's
like
I've dealt with network Executives who
it's like I felt like they didn't even
remember that we had a meeting and it's
like two weeks later we got a deal so it
happens yes
what are the five most common reasons a
movie idea will be rejected
I think the most obvious one is that it
is just out of sync with what the
company needs
so it's like
if it's just a genre or a style or you
know TV show movie whatever it's like if
if the project itself just does not mesh
with the core basics of what the company
Works Within
they're not gonna
they're not gonna like turn ship for you
you know
um I think a second reason after that is
if your project is too similar
two other things that are in the market
we work a lot with Christmas movies
uh Christmas romances and you would
think that there's like only five or six
versions of the same story you can tell
but the truth is it's infinite there's
always unique Slants you can take but if
it's too similar to something that
already exists in the market or has been
done especially recently that's
something that we'll just take a step
back and say it's not gonna not gonna
jive with us
um
third thing and I think this is where
you is you go deeper into this this is
when it gets a little bit
um I guess more fresh information for
writers who might not have visibility to
some of these more internal workings
so uh I would say a third reason is
when it focuses on subject matter or
interactions of characters
that just don't resonate well on screen
and so what I mean a good example of
that would be like something that is way
too social media heavy and I know like
social media is it I mean you can start
whole relationships in today's world via
app and another means so it's like
that's fine but it doesn't translate
really well on screen and so making sure
that visually from beginning to end this
project is actually going to make sense
that's pretty critical
and then you get to other things that
you know they don't talk about in
screenwriting books and they don't
necessarily pitch in film schools and
that's like what is the budget budget's
critical like if you're writing
something that is out of sync with the
real world value of what the movie is
it's not going to make any sense
so if you're writing
um a basic TV movie but you're writing
it at a budget that is way above that it
doesn't
correlate the company's not going to see
any Merit in it because they're going to
say we're not going to pay all this
money because we know where the metrics
are we know where the clients are in
terms of pricing uh and then if you go a
Step Beyond that I would say
um
I would say it's production related and
what I mean by that is
it's a script that is written in a way
that is not production friendly
uh most of the people who are reading
scripts have a lot of production
experience and they can read the script
and know like right away
at least ballpark this is how much these
things are going to cost whether it's a
TV series whether it's a movie they know
one of the SAG raids they know what are
the crew rates so if you have a script
with like way too many cast members way
too many expensive locations way too
many things that just are complicated to
make happen within the budget level of
what the project you're working on
should be it's going to get rejected but
that's why I kind of put it in that
category which is it's hard for writers
to know what those numbers are in the
book I wrote uh mastering the pitch in
each section of the book I kind of
devote a chapter to
um like movies and then TV shows and
reality TV shows and all that and I
actually put in there what are the
budgets supposed to be so we put those
in so you kind of get a sense of like
you know a high end of this would be X
dollars a mid-level would be this many
dollars and a low budget
professional not like micro budget
shoestring budget but like one that
could actually be on TV or like an
original for a VOD platform what would
that low budget look like so if you can
write at that budget level at a
production that makes sense for like 12
to 20 days of production you're starting
to kind of remove some of those layers
and then I would say I'd add a six to
that and that's just if the writer's an
if they're just complicated to
deal with
could be a good script and you'll just
pass on it what would a a low low budget
let's say film Christmas movie shot in
another state and let's sorry not
California maybe it's one that has tax
incentives B what would the budget for a
low budget uh so they scale
um
and we don't shoot any of them in LA
because La is extraordinarily expensive
to film and we shoot and and we don't
necessarily even shoot in the states we
do a lot in Canada and we do a lot in
Australia but and we do work a lot in
tax efficient States
um George is a great tax efficient state
but Netflix does so much there that you
know it's it's it's becoming a lot more
expensive to shoot there but there's a
lot of places we just shot a movie in
Kentucky we shoot a lot of places but uh
the general budgets are going to be
one million ish to two and a half
million
um but that is like total gross cost
that is like how much cash is required
to shoot the movie but the way we work
is that we are being quite
financially Savvy in terms of how we
structure deals how payments are paid
out how we classify things and then if
we work in a tax efficient States and we
work within very specific parameters and
we Source Talent and crew and utilize
local resources we can get what we call
soft monies or tax rebates like the idea
of soft monies is um that there's
incentive for us shooting these movies
in some of these different areas whether
it's like local municipalities or local
States Etc they want the business and so
they're willing to sort of uh really
make it worth our while to shoot there
instead of other places
so on our side of the business we're
looking for those opportunities you know
we know our scale of how much this stuff
needs to cost we know where we can shoot
it and how we can shoot it we also know
well how many characters do we need in
the movie so that we don't exceed our
budget how many locations do we need in
there so we don't exceed our budget
because you start doing company moves
that gets pretty pricey so it's it's a
combination of being able to maximize
soft monies tax rebates pre-sales when
they're possible license fees from a
client and a script that meshes with all
of that so if it's a screenplay that's
not fitting into that model it's it's
not really usable for us
what do you think about the advice write
the script or make the movie you want to
watch
look I mean I think uh
I wrote the books I wanted to exist when
I was younger like it's I think there is
something important to
um be able to uh Express what it is
you're trying to say I think that's
absolutely critical
um but I would
and and I have no problem like I I don't
want writers to think like they should
only write these genres and that they
should forever turn their back on any
passion project they have like their
passion is what got them into wanting to
do this in the first place they should
absolutely follow that at every step of
their career but what I'm saying is
utilize these core genres that do work
that are in need and apply what story
you want to tell within it like these
characters whether it's a tween girl
romance whether it's a female driven
Thriller whether it's a Christmas movie
like they even the creature features
like there are real stories and real
moments in there that are 100 purely
human interactions human conflict human
struggles uh and challenges that we can
all identify with
um you know there's a lot of kind of
stereotypical you would expect Sci-Fi
movies that actually have these very
powerful messages in them about how we
operate as as humans you can say that
about zombie movies what it really
reveals about who we are and I think
that they probably or a tween girl movie
what what it sort of tells about
whether you're male or female like what
what that feels like early in your life
when you're stumbling through this
transition of childhood to adulthood and
it's not just sex and puberty it's it's
all of the responsibilities that get
thrust on you and balancing how you grew
up versus what your personal experiences
of the world are and and all of that and
it's like you can funnel that into
something really fun and TV safe and
disney-esque and still be very you know
powerful in what you're trying to
communicate so I don't think that they
should dismiss it I think they should
utilize them
right let's let's say eighth grade did
you see that film I I didn't okay okay
so there were probably things that
wouldn't maybe be Advertiser friendly
for TV I loved it I know there was a
gentleman that walked out of the theater
when I was watching and I was surprised
but it sounds like for what you're
talking about is these are working
writers these are people that they
probably pay their rent pay their car
bill whatever through writing and if you
want to have a career you can you know
write the next precious which is amazing
but that's also very hard to get made
and so these are things that that are
consistent there's a there's a formula
to them and they work people people
watch them yeah and and I would add to
that like
if you want to have those moments of
being a staff writer on a series if you
want to have those moments of like that
passion project you want to see made you
need help to do it and you need a track
record to do it and you need
relationships to make that happen so
building a career showcasing you can do
the work you've done it consistently you
can be Dependable you deliver what you
say you're going to do time and time and
time again and you've showcased like my
stuff makes you money
um you're getting obviously paid for it
in exchange but like my stuff makes this
company money I'm delivering the goods
let's Elevate the relationship every
every person I know who's become a
director did it by working through the
ranks and proving they could do the work
before they actually got the job every
writer I've ever met proved they could
write before they got the job and if you
want to see your passion project made
you kind of have to showcase I get how
the industry works I'm totally in on it
I in terms of you know assisting and
playing my role and my part in making
that system operate and now it's my turn
to really put something forward and take
that first big leap you need help to do
it it's not I mean there's always
outliers I'm sure I'm sure you know
there's there's a couple of you know
pop-up titles sporadically here and
there that launched careers but for the
most part these overnight you know
success stories are like 10 15 years of
like hard dedicated work that finally
just crisscrossed into the big
opportunity
Boondock Saints yeah yeah that'd be one
of those stories and in truth that time
period that time era was very very
different and that was still when film
was the thing and theater was still what
it was and it wasn't being utilized
quite the same way it was today and uh
you know some of the personalities
picking that movie up or you know
they're they're how they are viewed in
history is very different in today's
world
um so a lot has changed since then and I
I don't I think it's really critical not
to hold yourself or judge yourself on
how other people built their careers or
what Milestones they hit and by what age
and when uh because you're gonna first
off you're gonna drive yourself nuts and
make yourself depressed and they were
operating in time periods and they had a
series of opportunities before them that
are just different you got to work with
the ones that are before you
but I think that if you want to get your
passion projects made
keep them going keep them in your back
pocket and it's important for Riders to
be able to like move from this project
to that project so that they're not
getting too involved and being able to
stay fresh on them uh but yeah if you
have that consistent work pattern and
you're getting regular deals you're not
selling out you're being professional
and you'll get those opportunities for
your own projects too sure and just as
distribution has changed and how we view
things sounds like how you get your
projects out there when you said you
read sidfield's screenplay excellent
advice and then the last chapter maybe
that's and I don't want to speak out of
school here but maybe it's outdated at
this point
in a sense like it goes back to
principles versus you know Trends and
all that like yeah I think the the
version of the book that I read like
suggested you still nail a hard copy
with a self-addressed stamped envelope
and all that stuff it's like our time is
just very different today but um the
concept of reaching out getting it in
front of people speaking learning how to
speak about your project
learning to speak with confidence which
is a skill in and of itself and it's one
that many people struggle with and it's
okay there's there's no shortage of
videos on YouTube to like learn how to
better present yourself but the truth is
you just got to get out there you got to
get your hands dirty you you got to get
your boots on the ground and and sort of
make the opportunities happen when
pitching should a writer speak 100 about
the story or should they also talk about
the business viability of the project I
think both I think
um
that's really at the end of the day what
it is it's it's a creative project that
answers a business problem and I think
screenwriters do need to view what
they're presenting as a business case in
addition to a story story is critical
and
um what happens in that story how it is
presented how it unfolds again even in
these like core genres that you think
are overly cliched it's like there's a
lot of story development and the number
of hours I've been on the phone or a
zoom talking about one project that's
just a A Christmas Story like it's it's
um it's quite intense uh but yeah it's
so story's critical but it being able to
answer the problems of the platform or
the network is also critical so when we
have those usually starts in this kind
of like process where it's first
I'm working with a writer and I'm
working with a network or VOD platform
separately I get the deal opportunity
closed then we get that script mapped
out written contracted Etc then we get
everybody in the room together and have
that big creative conversation and uh
yeah during that process it's we're
pitching the script but we're also
pitching it as a business case and why
it's going to make that company money or
why it's going to bring in audience or
what things does it need to have in it
that are going to help them grow their
grow their company grow Their audience
base or you know increase revenues and
when you're on a phone call back and
forth about a project for many months is
it is it story driven that you're that
you're just is it story based that
you're discussing issues or is it
location all of the above it's all of
the above I mean story you know is the
big filter It's gotta work the theme has
to work uh the character has to follow
the right Journey
um but how that happens yeah we we do
dive a lot into the
the tangible uh uh I guess technicality
of how are we actually going to execute
this thing because it's not just words
on the paper you're going to have to
have a crew behind the camera so if that
conversation is taking place in a car
while it's driving why like just
put it on a bench you know put it
someplace that's easy to shoot
um uh the number of characters and
there's you know I just had a
conversation with a writer um
a few days ago and she was very specific
about wanting a character in a scene
with no dialogue
because story-wise she felt it was very
important and I'm sort of in this
situation of sort of explaining yeah but
we got to pay all this extra money for
them to be on set for that one day and
they may not need to be there and it
does there is a kind of a balance in
terms of like cost economics Commerce
versus the creative storytelling budgets
are tight on a lot of Productions and so
you have to balance that so it's it's a
big hybrid
and it's usually you're talking both at
the same time on specific points
but story opens the door
and I would say the the um the details
of the execution the business case are
what close the deal
are there any pitching myths that
screenwriters should be aware of I don't
know if there's any like
specific myths but I would say the myths
would be
um
believing that like
there's one way to pitch that there's
like a memorized log line you should
have
that you go in and like they always call
it like the elevator pitch that like
this is your one shot and that's totally
not true at all and it goes back to the
whole principle of like pitching is
repitching it's like
you can repitch the same project dozens
of times it's okay but that idea that
like you're just going to memorize a log
line and you're going to say it once and
that you're going to get this big check
and like that's that's it's done that
that's a total myth and that's totally
not how it works in real life
um and then I would say another myth is
the quote we're buying it in the room
kind of idea that like
um that you go into your meeting you
present it and then like they buy it in
the room and all that it's like I know
there are like a handful of stories out
there of these things sort of happening
um what was the guy's name Joe Esther
house I think uh
you know it's like wrote an idea on a
napkin at a bar while he was hammered
and like you know made Millions off it
and it's like it's not quite really how
it worked the agent was out there to get
the next script of his because his
previous work was so successful they
didn't care what he put the job that
executive or agent or whomever did the
deal with him had was to basically like
write a check whatever he says and just
get something in writing that that's the
objective you know it's like
those I think kind of fall into myths
about how things work was this for Basic
Instinct I know Basic Instinct was his
original like that he he got so much
success for but then his like ladder
work
um I don't I don't know all the films
right right but it's like there was a
series of films that got made uh uh
after that and everyone was hoping to
get the cash cow Basic Instinct because
it was such a big success at the time I
don't know what 90 91 something like
that uh so like early 90s there were a
lot of those movies floating out there
big checks he's one of those very few
screenwriters
who had
that much control and that much clout
and
I don't know if he's in you know an
everyday you know a name that everybody
knows per se Even in our industry but
like there's quite a few people who know
his name over other screenwriters let's
say sure but those are rare those would
be your myths right it doesn't work like
that
never certainly I've never seen it
happen
well here's one myth identify an
untapped or underserved Market that is a
myth of
uh
uh this belief that because it's never
been seen before people therefore will
want to see it and
that's not true at all it's
um
I have seen some wacky projects
presented as opportunities that were
just like there's no audience for this
and it doesn't fit anywhere it's like
it's it's you're you're trying to pitch
or present
a character or a story that is uh I'm
not saying not relevant to very small
Circles of people but it's like it's so
limited it's just not gonna reach the
like viability of funding
if you want to make it go for it but you
got to find alternative sources for the
revenue but like just going in and
waving a script or a project and saying
it's never been seen before therefore
it's a ticket to an opportunity it's not
it's like it's got to fit into those
kind of core buckets and genres
why are fewer movies made for people
over age 55 because they buy less
generally they tend to not be
people who are will call them elderly I
guess it was still the politically
correct term now it's uh uh it's if
you're in that category of age you are
less likely to be buying or consuming
stuff products at the same rate somebody
who's in their 30s or their 20s would be
if you're talking theater tickets
older audiences don't go to the theater
nearly as often as younger audiences if
you're talking TV content they don't
watch nearly as much television as
younger audiences if you're talking
subscription VOD platforms they're not
as likely to be having six seven
subscription VOD platforms uh that
they're they're popping back and forth
between
um
as a result there's just fewer content
that is directed towards older audiences
and produced for them or the way you do
it is you find content that just
generally speaks to a larger demographic
of people that can be viewed there now
there are a couple of examples Colombo
Murder She Wrote uh was the the lawyer
show and they've done reboots of some of
these too
um
so there are and there's Acorn TV it's a
really good svod platform it was bought
by AMC networks and that's its real
Target demo is is that sort of like
middle aged to slightly older female
audience that's going to watch cozy
Mysteries like Miss Marple and you know
uh Agatha raisin and you know we did a
bunch of Doc Martin uh programs with
them and we did a few other uh uh shows
with them back with my previous company
so um there are outlets for them but
they're not nearly as many as younger
audiences
like I think it's that goes into one of
those things like myths it's it's just
because there's not content for older
audiences doesn't mean like well I'm
gonna write you know a movie that's
aimed at them because no one's doing it
and it's sort of a thing of like there's
a reason why there's not as much
produced for them
myth number two pitching is an art
yeah it's it's there's this belief that
um I think people have this belief about
a lot of things that like there's only
some people that can do it and they do
it well and it's like I really genuinely
don't believe that I think that there's
not one way to pitch I think what's
critical is that you pitch the way you
want to pitch
um it's not an art form in the sense of
like somebody is just brilliantly
skilled at it I mean obviously there are
people more comfortable walking into a
room and talking than others but your
ability to learn how to do it your
ability to improve your capability of
doing it your ability to present
yourself your ideas in a professional
way and be able to make a business case
for why your script or why your projects
should be taken seriously anybody can
learn this stuff not many people take
the time to learn it they're easy to
it's very easy just to say you know
somebody doesn't know what they're
talking about if they're like presenting
this kind of concept but it's like the
truth is you can teach yourself how to
do this you can teach yourself how to be
professional and how to talk the talk
walk the walk Etc
when people talk about pitching a
project are they talking about a big
Hollywood studio project or an
independent film Project like how are
they different and how would the
pitching be different
so
um
for somebody new to the industry
you're not gonna be able to go to
Paramount or Warner Brothers and just
like get on the lot and get to a top
executive and pitch
um there there's literally walls around
them so you're not going to get in uh
but uh if so if you're starting out you
would be working more with independent
Distributors production companies and
they are much more accessible and they
are producing way more content than the
studios are actually producing
at the studio level the way they work is
if you ever go to a lot
um
there's all these like random buildings
there's obviously the big sound stages
and then there's like the corporate
Executive offices but then there's all
these like random offices around the
place and those are production companies
generally contracted by the studio
to just essentially be a filter for the
studio to acquire content to develop
content specifically to go into the
studio machine
so again you're not pitching to the
studio you're pitching to that
production company that is in the sphere
of the studio we'll say
but how is it really different in truth
it's really not it's the numbers on
paper
can be sizably different but um
you know it's it's what things cost can
be different but as far as like being
able to pitch a genre
that is constantly in need being able to
pitch a story that fits that genre well
and being able to pitch a story that
fits that genre that is also
economically feasible and realistic to
produce
it's kind of the same across the board
now it's really hard to go in as
somebody who doesn't have a track record
and do that at the studio level for
multi-million dollar films but you have
a really good opportunity to do it at
the independent level and if you do it
consistently at the independent level
you can work your way up that's why I
really
present a lot of these ideas to help
people kind of start careers because
it's a long long tail game it's not
something that happens overnight and it
is something that you build over a long
period of consistent habits and good
work
and it's not something that happens
right out of film School certainly not
uh
uh it's it's you just it's it's not that
you know film schools don't teach
students like really good practical
skills and some film schools have
amazing programs that get students right
into Studios or internships Etc but you
need real world working experience and
uh that can take time to get and it's
it's realizing some of those ideas that
you get at Film School
that you just want to rush out there and
sort of Take On The World so to speak
which is amazing to have the passion but
being able to actually say okay now in
the real world how does this process
really work and it goes back to what are
the core genres what is what does
Hollywood need to function it's a giant
industry it's it's worth you know it's
it's multi-multi-multi billions of
dollars transacting it's it's you've got
to be able to help that machine function
and you've got to be useful within it of
the three books that you've written
Which chapter do you wish you'd had
advice on when you started in this
industry
that is an awesome question
um
I think
the most critical thing that I put in
all I put them in all three books that's
that's kind of how strongly I feel about
it it's realizing that very it's it's
two things it's realizing it's not
script to screen
it's the reverse of that it's you start
at the end which is what do people want
to watch and you work your way backwards
all through the process
what do people want to watch what genres
do they need how much does it need to
cost what is an IP that works and then
it goes back to okay who's going to
write it it's that process
and then realizing what distribution
actually was and how it actually worked
as a business because there's not many
of us in the distribution world it's a
pretty small group of people and a
pretty small handful of companies that
really work in it
um
but we're like making the bulk of the
decisions of what content gets created
and who creates it not not me personally
but I mean just the group of people
working in the distribution game I don't
think there's enough of that focused on
in film school at all
um I'm not sure why that is I am sensing
because the introduction to Media
distribution book has been adopted at a
couple of universities
um and it's we're getting a second
edition of it like it's getting some
traction and I think that that is
growing
but it's you got to understand
distribution and I think that was the
thing that I wish I knew I I will say
this I I when I first came out to LA I
like thought I was like
I thought I had it all figured out and I
just like it I had no idea what I was
doing when I got here and like
everything I thought I knew was wrong
and I could not figure out
how does this industry work I couldn't
figure it out and it wasn't until years
later I took my first what would be my
first distribution job and I took it
because I just needed a job because it
was like I was working on movie sets
doing lighting work and it was
inconsistent and it was either go back
to waiting tables in between jobs or go
get a real adult job so I did the latter
I got a real adult job and it turned out
to be a sales job in the business and I
I was I didn't even know you could sell
TV shows or movies and that all of a
sudden once I learned that process
everything started to make sense about
how the industry works and that's when I
started going to can that's when I
started going to all these markets and
all of a sudden I was on that side of
the table and I mean I was a production
assistant on my first movie and
I I was just dabbling project to project
a project and then uh just a couple of
years later I was in can and the
director of that movie was pitching me a
story so it's like it does it's it's so
the distribution thing is so critical in
terms of like that is the filter where
the whole industry crisscrosses through
that is the intersection
very long-winded way of saying I wish I
knew about distribution in film School